this was just 15 years ago nobody had
ever seen anybody like me on the air who
was just an average looking black person
gorgeous though I am no frills no
whatever and I look back at some of my
videotape I don't know how I got to be
successful myself wearing summit at
those hairdos and those outfits but
gorgeous though she is always understood
the impact that she and her
groundbreaking talk show had on this
country that is the subject of a new
exhibit watching Oprah The Oprah Winfrey
Show and American culture it will open
Friday at the Smithsonian's National
Museum of african-american history and
culture the exhibit features interactive
interviews movies costumes and artifacts
from the Oprah shows 24 25 year run
number one the whole time just saying
organizers say examines the ways that
America shaped Oprah and how her work
shaped our country today
Oprah is a major benefactor for the
museum it's also we're proud of this a
sixth special contributor yeah we are
glad that you are back at the table and
this I was saying to people this is what
you love more than anything is
discussing yourself because and I'm
being very sarcastic this is absolutely
what she hates but I didn't know Oprah
that you didn't realize what all was
going into the exhibit it's a big deal
4,000 square feet yeah it's in three
parts of your life your childhood the
show is it three parts of three parts
yep three parts and then the impact that
you've had on America but you weren't
involved in curating all the different
things that will be on display no
because I think they wanted to draw a
line between the fact that I had worked
as a part of the board to create the
museum and then not to have anything to
do with whatever was going into this
exhibit so I missed that meeting that
there was actually going to be an
exhibit yeah and so there were
archivists who've been working on it for
the past couple of years and I they
would come to me for and they really
work with my team headed by Amy wine
bloom and they literally you know we're
asking for Diaries and I was like let me
see if I can give up that Valerie and
looking for you know the first speeches
I wrote when I was 12 and all of that so
I'm not sure what's in it
was there anything that was a revelation
to you which either you said oh my gosh
I completely forgot that or that Rhys
entered you after all these years John I
can honestly tell you I don't know
what's in this exhibit I'm going to see
it for the first time today I've my
team's been giving up a lot of stuff
from the show over the years they've met
with most of the producers and so I
think I'm going to be surprised it'll be
like but you can talk about what it
means walking down memory lane yeah I
can't talk about that
I'm so proud actually of you know I've
known you for a long time but the fact
that this is happening and the fact that
it's happening to you makes me so proud
of what you've accomplished and I can't
imagine what it must be or feel like for
you well actually you know I just
because I'm I'm here to talk about the
book club later yes yes but also I knew
that you all were gonna be doing this
segment so I just started thinking about
this last night because I very much am a
present moment person and I hadn't given
it a lot of thought but as I was
thinking about it last night I thought
this is a really big deal and the thing
that makes me the most proud is that
it's about watching Oprah watching The
Oprah Winfrey Show and its impact on the
culture because there still is not it's
been off the air
7 7 years as of May 25th and there is
not a day that I go anywhere in the
world that there aren't several people
who come up to me and tell me about the
impact that shows had on them and that
is no small thing for me what what
people just say I love you so much and
your show that I said tell me what
actually happened and usually I end up
saying oh I get it I raised you because
people tell the story of coming home at
4 o'clock and turning on the TV and
watching with their mothers and my mom
always said you capture someone's heart
and you capture their mind mm-hmm and I
think you captured people's minds by
talking about issues that people weren't
talking about on television race sexual
abuse that's I was the first time we did
a show on alcoholism and there was a
family of five and I was like oh my god
I didn't know that white people had
dysfunction because I grew up thinking
that all white people were like Lee
to Beaver and so the first time I
started having conversations with people
with real dis dysfunctions with real
family issues from all parts of the
country it was a revelation to me but
here's the biggest thing when I had
finished doing my school and I was
sitting in Maya Angelou's kitchen you
know this yeah and I said to her Oh Maya
this is gonna be my biggest legacy the
school and Maya says you have no idea
what your legacy will be your legacy she
says is every life you touch your legacy
is every person who's ever watched a
show and made the decision they were
going to go back to school they were
going to talk about investing I'll just
say this Lonnie bunch the director said
Oprah Winfrey is a person people trust
just the way they trusted Walter
Cronkite and that's true we'll be right
back I'm excited about it me too very
much yeah